dans les rues de mario paul les chars
russes patrouillent slalomant entre les
ruines les habitants eux se cachent
chaque jour ils vivent dans la crainte
des bombardements
sergei lui a eu de la chance deux obus
ont touché sa maison sans qu'aucun
explose
c'est une chose très improbable que deux
bombes tombent même endroit chacune
aurait pu me tuer mais elles n'ont pas
explosé
ma mère me dit que ce jour là je suis né
une deuxième fois
seule option pour les habitants pris au
piège essayer d'évacuer face aux caméras
les troupes russes soignent leur image
les soldats leur fournisse un peu de
nourriture et un abri certains les
suivent sans savoir pour autant où ils
sont emmenées
selon les estimations 80 à 90% de la
ville aurait été entièrement détruite
depuis le début du conflit la plupart
des combats se concentrent pour l'heure
dans une zone industrielle toujours aux
mains des ukrainiens marie paule est
devenue le point névralgique du conflit
a posé une autre position à marioupol
est forte plus notre position dans l'est
le sera ninja y ait plus l'opposition
sera forte dans l'opération des forces
conjointes et
qui nous sommes plus forts et
négociations seront plus proches et nous
aurons l'avantagé dans les pourparlers
avec les troupes russes
selon les autorités russes environ 300
mille civils seraient toujours coincées
à marioupol et près de 5000 aurait été
tué et les ukrainiens eux avancent un
bilan beaucoup plus lourd